well I was I was sick when I was a kid
in fact that's when I said I was never
going to go near any hospital again if I
could avoid it well I end up in the
business sort of sort of odd but one of
the things i like is is technology and
gadgets and I I love seeing the process
of solving problems and I worked in a
hardware store actually when I was 14
and I was able to work my way up to not
just being a stock person but actually
talking to customers what I loved best
is I would ask the customer to tell me
what is it you're trying to do and then
working with that customer to try to
solve that problem and it was usually
not the way they were thinking of it
going over to the island filing the
finding the product that just does it it
was combining several things that would
customize the solution for that problem
that they were thinking of and that was
really a lot of fun and rewarding not
only because of the you know solving the
problem but these great relationships
you have with people
I think that being science and math
literate and technology literate is is a
fundamental requirement for any liberal
arts knowledge that you cannot be an
effective citizen today without having
that capacity to understand I'm not
saying you have to be a scientist or an
engineer I'm saying being science
literate so that you can understand and
appreciate I mean even understanding the
movies and understanding plays and books
requires some science literacy and and
so I'm fascinated and passionate about
making sure kids have that basic
understanding but also that they have
the opportunity to go on and pursue it
at a greater depth
I'm involved with first first is
actually a robotics competition that was
started by Dean Cayman and the
philosophy to do what you just said how
do you motivate kids to want to learn is
based in first which is let's use the
sports model let's not focus on the
supply side of the equation will you
develop more great programs in schools
let's focus on the demand side of the
equation let's make this really fun
you're competing in a sport but in fact
the sport is designed so that in order
to win you've got to work in teams
therefore you've got to collaborate you
have to do more than just one little
task you've got to put things together
with your team so that it actually works
and it can play with other teams and
you're not only going to learn to
collaborate with your team mates but the
game's design so in order to win you
actually have to collaborate at
different times with your opponent and
that of course is really the way
capitalism was designed perhaps those
bankers in New York lost the lesson
someplace but in fact are creating that
environment really is a culture changing
phenomenon and I've already told you how
important I think culture is but I think
if you watch it the answer to the
question is watch kids go through that
sort of process in environment you'll
see kids who really had no chance kids
from inner cities where the real problem
was disciplined in the school and in
fact whether you're a young girl
definitely in some young boys being
knowledgeable is a liability in your
social life being knowledgeable in
science and math is really the kiss of
death for a girl getting a date but in
the case of first that's not the case
we're actually it's it's
about thirty percent female and in about
thirty percent minority in in different
areas and the idea is that creates a
whole network of people with common
shared values and therefore if you're
good at science then you are high on the
pecking order of what people rank very
high and it's it's not only just being
tough that way of winning a game you
don't win by making the opponent lose
which is which is true in a lot of
sports today that's why why trash talk
was invented it's intimidation it's make
your opponent do worse and you will win
my view is ultimately for sustainable
society you want to constantly raise the
ladder get better and better and that is
the environment that which tries to
strive to achieve and first and watching
those kids and they will tell you and
we've got 130 colleges and universities
that have engineering and technology
programs that provide over 12 million
dollars worth of scholarships for any
kid who has gone through a first program
and can meet their route and you know
admission requirements why does that
happen because everything else being
equal they say those kids do better
they've learned to work in a team
they've learned to work on our budget
they've learned to work in with schedule
they've learned how to settle debates
they have mentors of course that do that
so that's the environment that I think
we need to provide to get more of the
the kids who are going to allow us to
compete against the rest of the
countries in the world who are getting
better than we are
well I suppose it would be inappropriate
to say we suck but unfortunately we've
taken a terrible terrible downturn and
and the statistics that quoted all over
the place they might even very you can
argue were the numbers but it's more
like we're 20th out of 30 or 25 out of
25 compared to our major competitors and
that doesn't even take into account the
China is an India's of the world
statistics point out that the u.s. is
has been declining in its
competitiveness in a lot of different
ways one of them is is this whole issue
of do you have to understand science and
math and we've been graduating a lot of
people from high school who literally
are illiterate in in in science and math
in in the case of math is called in
numeracy and that sometimes shows up at
high management levels you could even
argue that it showed up on Wall Street
this past year or two but in order to
get around that we need to make it
desirable on the part of the kids in in
hiring of the young today it's very
interesting you can see the people who
are in the US but foreign born they want
to learn they want to work whereas with
a lot of our born in the US types they
are looking for the perfect life being a
rock star or bouncing a ball and that's
not a sustainable model
you